[Music]
hi thank you for coming to our
presentation and we're gonna speak about
our product Amazon a data discovery
platform from left hi my name is shin
I'm an engineer phone left my name is
Tao I'm an engineer a live so we're
going to talk about how the data
ecosystem looks like in overview at left
and the challenges with the data
discovery that we have a left and the
solution that we provided at left and
then we're gonna have a short demo and
give you a high-level overview of the
architecture and the summary so in this
big data error almost every employee in
the company are actually the user of the
data platform we categorize as seven
user parents personals that uses the
data data modelers that working on
modeling data data analyst data
scientist proto managers general
managers engineers as like me and
experimenters experimenting the data
here are the users and here are very
simplified overview of lift data
infrastructure from the left as you can
see there's a smartphone using lift app
pushing the event without of events to
the server where the server relays into
the message message platform which we
use kinases and Kafka here and also
there's a services directly pushing
event as well and we have a flank
framework that doing streaming
processing purses into distributed file
system we use Amazon s3 on this from
there we have hundreds of airflow tags
doing ETL into Amazon redshift which is
our legacy data warehousing hive bet by
parque format industry and therefore a
real-time use case we use through it
which is real-time database
they lived in this databases we also
have third PI vendors to visualize the
data such as looker mod tableau we also
have open source visualization layer
superset and there are many other custom
apps that consuming this data this is
very simplified view of lift data
ecosystem but as you can see is quite
different from like a past years where
there were only one Oracle database or
sequel server so there's a problem with
here that comes with the data discovery
where the data lives and what does that
mean so let's say you're do be data
scientist and you go to your desk and
then your forgot the first project there
is analyzing and predict the data
council attendance so this is your
project so how do you get this done so
the first thing to figure out is how to
predict the data you need to analyze the
past data right so the natural question
will be where's data and even if you
find the data the probably there are
many columns over there what does it
mean so current solution without any
like a provided system my solution will
be like you can email the friend you can
select them probably not a phone these
days but email and you can proactively
do the search in github or if your
company provide code search you can do
the core search on them and then let's
say you find some table several of them
and that table has like dunces dozens of
fields and each field
mostly does not have like good comments
on there so you lost contacts over there
like let's say there's a tendons field
does attendance field include employees
why this is important because you
probably want to know figure out the
revenue from that and your employees not
including the revenue so the media
to understand more so the typical way to
understand the data here is just to
issue the curry like good old fashioned
select all from certain partition and
you need to sample it because there's so
many data over there
the problem with select all is like is
it provides lack of productivity because
there are a couple of our table that you
already have you need to do this but
even before that if you don't have your
system set up to do the select all then
you need to do the connection setup as
well as get the permission that you
waste a lot of time if before even
before doing the Select query and also
it increased load on the databases as as
data scientists population grows and
your company so before we start working
on this data discovery solution we
actually did a research on how data
scientists spending their time like
they're spending on time on their main
work analysis which is one third of them
and then another one third is like
waiting for quarry and do the operation
work surprisingly the rest one third
they're spending on pay the discovery
problem basically try to understand what
the data is where it exists who owns it
who uses it and how to regress the
access so that's why we start building
the data discovery solution and here are
the audience that we primarily focus on
for our initial launch which are the
analysts and the data scientist which
are mostly working on full-time on data
discovery so we subcategorize three
personals on this data analyst and data
scientist one is power user who has all
the information of data on their hand
probably Alzheimer because they have all
the information on their head they got
interested a lot with a new a lot of
questions there are newbie users
especially if your company are growing
there are a lot of new users in Europe
in your team although there are very
experienced under experimenting with the
data they're basically lost in the data
discovery world because every company
has their own domain knowledge so they
need to ask a lot of questions to their
power users you can easily see there's a
friction on here and a lot of protein to
being lost because only to figure out
what kind of questions to ask who need
to whom the whom they need to ask and
power user keep getting interrupted here
third person is manager where there are
more likely over citing their product
data pipeline and they're more
concerning on dependencies rent lending
on time and communicating with
stakeholders who own the data who will
be affected with the summit starts an
SLA being missed so with our solution we
also try to solve theory kind of
question on this data discovery problem
the first is quite intuitive a search
based if you're looking for let's say
data council attendance you just search
for that term and then we're gonna find
it for you where's the table or
dashboard for certain term what does it
contain
as well as like if you're doing try to
do the analysis if that alice is already
exist which means a dashboard for
example the other solution with that we
are thinking to provide this linear
space let's say you already searched the
data and now you have a different
problem you are trying to change the
data and who will be affected and who I
should contact either owner or the most
common users that to discuss how this
change can be migrated I think the
search base and linear space is
quite well-known problem but I think our
product is quite exploring this part
that work based and which is like
basically if you think of like a
Facebook or Twitter you basically follow
some friend or follow some user we
basically try to accommodate that in our
data discovery problem so let's say
you're newbie on the team you probably
don't want to look at others power users
shoulder and so basically we're gonna
provide that feature for you you want to
follow the power user you can see what
they're you what kind of table they're
using what kind of dashboard they are
following so we're gonna provide that so
that we you can quickly up to speed so
with this we created a product called
Amazon for those people who are not
familiar with Wilson he's the first
person to discover the South Pole he's a
Norwegian explorer and we thought that
is quite a good match with our discovery
product so this is the first page of
Amazon and it's quite similar to Google
like there's a one big text box here
looking for a user to type in their
keyword and we also provide some like
tables in here
purple tables we call it for the new
user to just quickly go in without
typing the search so once you put your
search tags into the text box and then
press enter we provide you the result
and this is a how we compute the search
is actually not like a isolated to MSN
problem but is quite a common to search
domain like there's a two factor in
search and one is relevance and the
other one is popularity so let's say you
search Apple on Google and you have two
data set orange and Apple which one do
you think is more relevant probably
Apple right so let's say you search
Apple on Google you have a two data set
again Apple has a fruit Apple calm as a
company well which one do you think is
more popular sample com that's how
Google compute their page ranking to see
how many connection they have on to that
company I'm pretty sure there are more
complex algorithms out there but this
the high level idea so basically we
adopt this idea into our product so we
have a balance of relevance and
popularity so we use a table name column
name table description column
description and custom tags to provide
relevance and properly we basically
parsing user sequels to get the table in
column and also parse the table and
column from the dashboard to get the
properly basically these are in reaching
our graph okay back to the UI so once
you get this result let's say you click
one of the result it gives you to the
table detail page on the top left it
gives you the name of the table below
that provide you the availability of the
data which is a partition range if you
are more familiar with that word and
also table description which is editable
it provides you a list of columns and
types with the
metadata with a description as well and
which you can also add it as well on the
right side there each set of metadata
here which may give you like who owns
this table so that you can ask them what
what kind of data this is and also you
can see the who are the top five
frequent users frequent user here means
that they're the user who are calling
this table a lot you can ask them
question more about like in customers a
consumer perspective we also provide
some small set of linear information by
providing which application wrote this
and the source code location and this is
a better feature here we also provide a
table lineage we are using some third
pipe third party vendor that is a table
linear so we provide link on that we
also give you like a preview of the data
as well as export with Seco we integrate
with a superset so this is preview
nothing to see that much because
everything is redacted here but
basically give you a little bit of
feeling more feeling on the data and
also we provide the statistics of the
each column as well basically try to
give you more feeling about the data one
thing couple of things that would be
helpful be if that column has know how
many distinctive value it has just to
give you more understanding on the data
itself okay last but not least we been
launched this product for more than six
months and this feature has been very
successful on our side because we built
in the user feedback into our product is
give user profile rating bug report and
new feature request and we continuously
getting this and then improve ourself ok
yes
I will do the quick demo so because of
security reason I can only search for
one table you can search for other
things as well here but this is one
table actually if you see here this is a
event from the Amazon itself we are
actually logging all the user action so
that we can improve we basically want to
know how user are using our product so
let's say you click this one okay so it
show you the table you show you the
purchase partition availability there's
some description so you can basically
add the description here and there are
columns here as I mentioned there's a
statistics here you can also add it the
description to give you a better
description here and you can also add
owner frequent users most are tentative
of developers because it's our own table
and it was able to fetch like which
application it wrote table lineage as
well as preview data and if you click
this it will redirect you to the
superset so that you can do the more
extensive quarry over there you can add
the tag basically helping helping you on
the search and this is the feedback that
I mentioned last thing is on the bottom
you show you how fresh the Amazon is so
we got refreshed this morning
okay so the next part will be the brief
introduction of architecture but to make
it more interesting we built this open
source in mind so if you are interested
in collaborating with us we will be
great too for a high-level snippet on
the open source we we made many part of
pluggable so that you can plug like a
private code into our services such as
like we are
I mentioned that we are Amazon itself is
emitting events you can inject your
event emitter to our code we also have
using Python blueprint which is you can
plug in your API endpoint if you need
and now going to talk about this but our
ingestion engine is like a Lego break so
you can mix and match like like this is
open source you can add your private
transformer things like that so I will
hand it over to Tao
Thank You Ching so now let me talk about
waste architecture or emotions so
amundsen is a micro service architecture
it consists of three micro services like
a furnace services a metadata services
and such service and a data builder
ingestion layers how we talk about each
components in more details first start
with the front-end service furnace
services is written in reactors and
Flast web framework is a use as a portal
for user interaction for data discovery
so to recap watching is mentioned he is
like a table detail page at the mock
Forte TT voltage he has a rich right
here some metadata like table names
column names current descriptions what
the watermarks for the tables omnes
frequent users etc all this metadata has
been powered by the underneath metadata
service so let's go into voice metadata
service so metadata service is just a
simple C layer which currently leverage
the new photograph database as a
back-end to power the metadata request
for both front end services as
other microservices and live currently
live were you that who microservice
using our method ingesting metadata into
our meditation is machine learning
feature service which is used to
generate features for training purposes
they ingest like the features related
hacking into a metadata for better
feature discovery the other is a secure
compliant service which general security
related tagging for 4 compliant purposes
so a monsoon star with as a data
discovery tool now move a leaf we move
into a lot more I've met metadata
engines which not only for data
discovery is also used to ingest all the
metadata for other service airlift so as
mentioned we use currently ship with
neo4j as default but we work with some
other company to kind of support using
Apache Atlas which is a popular open
source project as another option to as a
graph backend so when we design the
metadata serviced a couple of trade off
we have made the first will be why we
choose graph database not the other
so to recap what answer these questions
so let's recap a bit on the data typical
live workflows so a live mobile client
application a which code file is a
location into a um B which could later
on consumed by our streaming in just
frame boxy and write to a Roya main
table T so and then later on there's a
we have a fo deck which is a ETA which
are you tell framework which reaches a
high ROI event table and write to derive
high table this derive table F could
have multiple multi problems
in this case have 5 columns ith ijk
of these five columns there's three
columns have been read and used by a
user named L you could see like this
workflow user is a actually is a graph
Israeli see the model will graph as each
component is a is a vertex and connected
the muse will be edges there are other
database in
yeah offering in the industry like one
year could be one category could be a no
sicko database like Cassandra and
dynamodb they do have like performance
good performance but they don't have
good supporting joint which is quit
essential to model this relationship the
other will be the traditional RTP MSI or
co-op post quests
they do have join support but they don't
have that joint performance is not very
good once the number no has been
increased into a certain scale so in the
end we choose neo4j as a back-end as
near future is the most popular graph
database so here this diagram is a is
the metadata graft which power the table
use a table detail page we just show so
the central node is the table knows
which had orders table metadata you
connect with the column notes with a has
column relationship and collect with the
table description with the has
discussions relationship connect what a
model can now whichever that generate
this table can now which user has been
used with this table and also we have
some extended metadata like column
statistic which connect with the column
so and so forth so suit us the second
trader we have may decide why not
propagate metadata back to the source so
what does it mean so before Amazon is
point like a lot of newbie another
sequel ask questions like should we use
this table is it columns it has been
deprecated is this column has been used
for this kind of purpose before Amazon
is born is the domain expert we answer
this question in slag and then we
actually this answer we get lost in
couple months after Amazon is born we
encouraging evangelize those domain
expiration update the table description
as well a column description to reflect
this kind of domain knowledge so
speaking about this description the
initially generated when user crea
key hub Sasa defined this table which
run and later on this description
proceeded into high Modesto and persists
into a neo4j graph one question will be
once used once
this domain expert has updated these
descriptions should we propagate this
description back to the source so first
of all I live it's very difficult to is
well it's very difficult to persist this
description modified description back to
the city hub source files each key hub
modification require only check but
should we propagate this modified
description back to hi Modesto in our
initial implementation actually we did
that so we did propagate back to
hammerstone but it's I come with a
caveat it doesn't have work with those
full we build table meaning like every
time the table is repealed
like all this modify this question we
lost so a live rehabber I have about 20%
of those table are full we bill so an
initial solution just disabled this
discussion editing for those full review
table but later on we heard from a user
feedback saying like this food which
will table our actually where wearable
and still will be good to support a
discussion modification so in the end we
choose to decided to improve in the
second version which cheat Amazon
metadata grab as the codon sauce for
this cushion and never propagate this
description back to a sauce you only
pick up the description for high middle
so when that table is newly created so
next let me talk a bit about the search
service search service is just a
Autolite metadata service is a simple C
layer using the elastic search to power
the search request from front end
services it support different search
query bottom line the typical normal
search pattern or category search as
well as wild-card search let's let's
talk a bit about like what's a challenge
we designed here like how to make the
search with our more relevant so to
answer these questions we we first need
to define a search quality metric which
could measure like what kind of
optimization will change our search
algorithm which could help to improve
our search quality and if we use
internal user magical click story with
our city our which is a typical campaign
magic which we use to measure the
percentage of people click the top-5
result when we do the instrumentations
we found that actually our initial
search card is not very quick for
example some other user when they try to
search a table it doesn't end up being a
first or second a first or second entry
but it goes to fifth or six pages the
other will be users sometimes get empty
result which this come with the second
point is I because we have a great good
instrumentation you help us to
understand all this user behavior in the
end based on the use of eBay as well as
this us logging we have we do couple
improvements first when people is
searching an exact table main we boost
those a search without wrecking so that
you will come into the top four sort of
second result and we also support
wild-card search so some of our table
are well a very long name with support
well cast such allow user to kind of see
search those a table even a assuming
they don't the had typos and also with
support category search for example in
this case we want to search all the
table with certain specific column like
in this case I want to search all the
tables with column is underscore line
right so forth data builder so they the
Builder is our ingestion layer to pull
the order may put a metadata from the
source and persist into our graph it
comes without even challenge when we're
building this like first is I live we
have many different forms of metadata so
as shown before we have like many data
database library hive as well fo DAC
OLAP to it Postgres a presto view we
also use many - but - like supercell mo
tableau all these different metadata it
doesn't have a single standardization
meaning doesn't have is no single data
model that could fit for all them data
source the second is that they you they
all use different extraction pattern has
some use the DBA API to fetch some use
some external API to fetch
- but some are using like geek hook to
fetch a source code so second challenge
is like you pull model versus push model
so what does it mean poom poom Otto
means wherever that upstream source or
database helps any change
we don't fetch this metadata
instantaneous or in near real time but
we fetch in a leverage some ETL
framework to fetch this updated metadata
in a fixed schedule and purposes into a
data graph push model mean if there's
any change in the upstream source this
upstream source or database will send
additional event into a message in queue
which will be consumed by a near
real-time framework into a graph so the
plus side of a pool model is when you is
not easy to define a single single data
model single interface for all the
metadata or is also good if you don't
need a Whitney real-time support but but
the dance I will be once this metadata
consumption has been grown with many
organization or many different team is
hard to scale because it's not easy to
write a data ingestion color for each of
these metadata source
push model is good if you could define a
single interface to model all these
metadata change and you also have
real-time effects so that people could
see the metadata changing
instantaneously and if we start with
using the pool model because at that
time when we start building a Munson
calf cast infrastructure has just
bootstrap is not that reliable now we
are moving to a hybrid model meaning
like we combine and leverage both pool
model as well a push model so this is
what actual data builders looks like
this circle is this data Beautif ream
work is highly inspired by the popular
data integration framework named Apache
Goblin it consists of four phases like
extractor
transformer loader and publisher here is
an example like this examples shown like
we pull the metadata from hi
and persist into a neo4j graph he use
first a high table metadata constructor
which extract the record from high
method store and put transfer into the
no up no up transformer and then there's
no up transformer because we don't need
to do any transformation in this case we
pass to the fast system near for JC s we
load up loader to load it into a staging
area as a civilized CSV files and then
later on used by the new for J CSV
publisher to publish that Meletus change
into our near photograph a Ching
mentioned is it's like a Lego block you
could use I either our open source
[Music]
extractor or transformer or you could
have your own private private version so
this show as an example which very
simple you just plug and play use
whichever you want and then put some
some kind of config to define and then
test it so I live we use Apache fo which
is a popular workflow orchestration
framework to orchestrate this data
builder job we want like this data
builder or metadata job to running
certain sequence we want the table
metadata to to kick off first to
generate all the related table metadata
once that is finished then generally all
the extend metadata like was the
high-water mark low-water mark for this
table was a table statistic which deck
has generally stable so on and so forth
and after everything is finished we we
run our last job or last task here for
term which is called last updated times
generally the last updates times them to
show the data freshness of our metadata
graph so what's next
so amazement seems to be more useful
than we thought so I live we have been
used by many different personas like
even customer service has been used out
to so we we think many organizations
have similar problem so we we are
currently a collaborate with some
external company and we plan to announce
the open source very soon so talking
about the impact
so this is our weekly active user our
Amundson usage and lift
we call it the mba graph because they
only have x-axis but it doesn't come
with a y-axis so when we initial launch
we come to alpha phases of our release
is only available with certain users
once we adopt the user feedback and do
some improvement we move on to the beta
release which internal release which
show us a huge jump once that is a beta
release we do a lot of improvement in to
improve our absurdity in power
reliability up to our tool and also
setting up the page fill out our tooling
and then move on to GA and then you
could see a huge jump then we see a huge
dip because it's a Christmas no one is
working a leaf at that time so no one is
using our - so once everyone is back we
see our - has been steadily user has
been static curry
so in summary so what's next so kindly
we've we finish adding table as the
first dataset into our resource we plant
we currently actively working on adding
like dashboards about people into our
data resource we want to light show some
of the heavily used dashboard and
showcase I'll allow user to discover as
well showing what abated opening expert
what table they are used the most which
table they own once that is finished we
also want to add like kafka stream as
well as the ideal schemas or ml water
flowing into our into across so in
summary we found like a good data
discard tool like where as 30% more
productivity to our data scientists and
we believe metadata is the key to our
next gen big data application and a
monsoon is that our living produced
metadata data discs are platform we have
a blog posts with this calling and we
also have a reason to give an interview
with a software engineer daily about
about who you more detail you could
check you just released yesterday you
could check out as well so thank
I just quit question if you're authoring
a workflow how much work you need to do
to plug into this system so I author
airflow job I produce some park a file
somewhere how do i plug data into the
metadata system that you can't extract
from the hive meta store or something so
you can surface all this metadata so to
clarify your question do you want to
plug in your airflow that information
into Amazon is that well I want to be
able to connect the data asset to the
airflow task that was in the UI so so
you chop this thing up you that job
region it was one single metadata is a
if you're familiar with air for you
would be just a Pisan operator job in
live in this case you just write a
Python function and call that date had
called the data build a library function
yeah hi
so when you were showing the process of
data builder and the metadata extractors
did the hide meta store extractor does
that come out of the box with Edmonson
what's the last part does the hive
metadata extractor come with Edmonson
yes it's part open source because is
basically talking with my sequel
instance of hide matter store that's a
pretty deep well defined so we embedded
it into our open source does that mean
there's other this last question does
that mean there's other metadata
extractors that come with Edmonson that
aren't the hive one currently mostly we
support hive as a table resource but you
can easily come up with so on the bottom
you can see the sequel alchemy extractor
so basically supports like post square
as redshift so if you just know the
quarry to how to get the information out
of those database you can easily plug in
[Music]